this week's Bitcoin update is a little
bit different than most there's only one
thing that's worth talking about and
it's the Federal Reserve if we go all
the way back to 2020 remember when
pandemic hit we saw the Federal Reserve
step in and do two emergency rate cuts
and they put interest rates down at zero
percent now that artificial dropping of
the interest rate of course incentivize
people to come in and borrow Capital
invest and drive asset prices to the sky
now when that occurred everyone felt
great we'd quickly recovered from a
recession that started in q1 of 2020 but
as most things happen too much of a good
thing can be a bad thing and we saw not
only asset prices continue to go up and
up and up into bubble territory but we
also saw consumer goods go up in price
as well that's where we got high
inflation which started in June of last
year over five percent and continued to
be over seven percent by the end of last
year of course inflation has only
compounded and now we're sitting at over
eight percent on top of last year's six
and seven percent and now the Federal
Reserve they've been talking tough for
months been raising interest rates
they've been creating tighter Financial
conditions but as many people thought in
the last couple of months asset prices
had come down significantly there's tech
stocks that are down over 80 percent
Bitcoins down 70 percent shouldn't the
Federal Reserve be saying no Moss
they're gonna be done well this past
week the Federal Reserve did another
interest rate hike 75 basis points but
not only was the interest rate hike
interesting but the comments afterwards
is what I would be paying attention to
Fed chairman Jerome Powell he had very
tough words he talked a lot about pain
p-a-i-n that word pain was a common
theme he's talking about pain in the
housing market and the need for a
correction in that market in order to
get inflation to come down he also
started to talk about a previously
thought strong labor market going to
have to weaken that's the only way
inflation will come down if you go back
and you look over the last nine or ten
months the Federal Reserve has said over
and over again their goal is to destroy
demand destroy demand sounds like a
crazy idea but they're actually being
successful in it housing is coming down
unemployment is ticking up and inflation
has been particularly sticky the Federal
Reserve understands that they're gonna
have to bring bigger and bigger weapons
to this fight if they actually are going
to get inflation down now you can debate
whether they will end up being
successful or not but you can't debate
the fact that they're committed to
Bringing more pain to the market that
pain tends to flow down to average
citizens into businesses and so you
should expect housing to continue to
correct you should expect interest rates
to continue to go up and you should
expect more and more layoffs that is not
a good situation for a country that
already is in a recession with two
consecutive negative growth quarters of
GDP ultimately Bitcoin coin it is a
separate asset it is outside of the
system to some degree but at the end of
the day the Federal Reserve is in
control it's all one big trade right now
most asset prices their correlation is
going towards one If the Fed continues
with their blunt weapons of interest
rate increases and quantitative
tightening we are going to continue to
feel pain in financial markets that pain
won't stop until the FED waves the white
flag and ultimately stops their current
track at that point they'll pivot and we
will return to a loose monetary policy
when that happens though is anyone's
guess if you're a Bitcoin investor the
most important thing to pay attention to
right now is nothing in the Bitcoin
Market it's simply the Federal Reserve
as the FED has destroyed demand and
they've brought all of these asset
prices down almost 80 percent of Bitcoin
investors haven't sold their Bitcoin
they continue to hold but it doesn't
matter the price continues to fall we're
now trading at below nineteen thousand
dollars that that's because people
realize the FED means business and the
FED is committed it'll be fascinating to
watch this play out over the coming
weeks and months but listening to Jerome
Powell openly talk about a weaker labor
market a housing correction and pain for
the economy
that's not exactly what you want to hear
if you're along any financial asset
these weekly updates I enjoy putting
together today is a little bit different
than most because it's really just one
big trade there's only one thing to
focus on but every week we bring these
to you in partnership with FTX if you're
interested go click on the link in the
description to learn more FTX has super
cheap fees buying Bitcoin
cryptocurrencies sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
they also offer digital stock trading
with no payment for order flow or
transaction fees go check out FTX today
and I'll see you all next Saturday for
the next Bitcoin weekly update hey you
did you like this video great make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time